When you work on the NCIS team, your life
is always on the line — and many beloved
characters have paid the ultimate price in
pursuit of justice.
Let's take a look at what some of these actors
have been up to ever since their NCIS character
went kaput.
Played by Sasha Alexander, former Secret Service
Agent Caitlin Todd was fiercely intelligent
and could easily craft detailed psychological
profiles of her suspects on the spot.
She was smart, but not immortal: In season
2, she's caught off guard by a terrorist cell
in a warehouse and ultimately assassinated
by a sniper.
This grisly development caught viewers completely
by surprise, especially since she'd already
been shot once during the episode.
A bulletproof vest saved the day the first
time around, but alas, she wasn't so lucky
the second time.
Since leaving NCIS, Alexander landed the plum
role of medical examiner Dr. Maura Isles on
another crime drama, Rizzoli & Isles.
She also had a recurring role on Shameless
as Helene Runyan, and has appeared in supporting
roles in films like Yes Man and He's Just
Not That Into You.
Played by Alan Dale, former NCIS Director
Tom Morrow still felt a certain responsibility
towards his old team after retiring from the
job but that commitment ultimately cost him
his life.
Still, he really knew his stuff just listen
to this:
"She worked at the Russian embassy in Turkey.
The raid went pear-shaped and she was killed!
Not ideal, but mission accomplished."
"Meaning?"
In the Season 13 episode, "Return to Sender,"
Gibbs visits Morrow's home and finds him very
much dead in his office.
We later find out he was killed by Trent Kort,
a former CIA operative who proved to be the
worst kind of traitor.
Once Morrow's time on NCIS was up, Dale joined
the cast of the Dynasty reboot in 2007, playing
the role of Carrington family majordomo Joseph
Anders.
"I know I'm going to regret asking, but what
exactly is going on?"
Dale got his start on the popular Australian
soap opera Neighbours beginning in 1985, and
made two subsequent guest appearances on the
show in 2018 and 2019.
"Ah, you know, I have a real chance now with
Jane."
"AH.
THE LOVELY JANE."
The death of Special Agent Michelle Lee was
a shocker.
Played by actress Liza Lapira, Lee served
on the Major Case Response Team... and she
was hiding quite the secret.
She was a mole who was constantly leaking
classified and sensitive information.
When the truth is discovered, she confesses.
Later on in the episode, Lee sacrifices herself
to stop her handler, Ted Bankstan, from escaping.
He uses her as a human shield, and she gives
Gibbs the signal to shoot through her.
Lapira has appeared in quite a few films since
leaving the show.
She played Sophie Trinh in the 2009 film Fast
and Furious and memorably portrayed smart-alecy
Liz in Crazy, Stupid, Love.
More recently, Lapira played Mia in the Netflix
series Unbelievable, based on the true story
of two female detectives investigating an
assault case.
Played by Muse Watson, Michael Franks is the
man who mentored Gibbs and he was an invaluable
member of the NCIS team.
Unfortunately, Franks wound up being brutally
stabbed by a serial killer outside of Gibbs
house.
Watson is set to appear in the horror film
The Dead Ones, and he's landed a role on the
upcoming miniseries Diary of a Lunatic, a
follow-up to the film Diary of a Lunatic:
Trew’s Calling.
In 2005, Lauren Holly joined the cast of NCIS
as Jenny Shepard, the new Director of NCIS.
The character is subsequently killed off in
the Season 5 episode "Judgement Day: Part
1" after she's cornered by gun-toting assassins
in an abandoned diner.
She doesn't survive the encounter… but at
least she proves to be exceedingly difficult
to kill.
Following her exit from the show, Holly was
cast as Dr. Betty Rogers on the mystery series
Motive a stint that began in 2013 and ended
in 2016.
She also plays the troubled Lynn Harper in
the third season of Designated Survivor.
Played by Matt Jones, Ned Dorneget's time
with the NCIS team didn't last long, but he
was an integral part of the crew for several
seasons.
The character died valiantly as he tried to
lead hotel guests to safety following a bomb
threat.
Unfortunately, that threat wasn't an empty
one.
Dorneget may no longer be with us, but Jones'
career is certainly alive and kicking.
Since 2013, he's played the lovable bad boy
Baxter on the critically acclaimed series
Mom.
It's safe to say this is much lighter fare
than NCIS.
"You don't make a habit of burying money in
my backyard, do you?"
"I'm not really sure that's any of your business."
Jones is also featured in the wacky TV show
Let's Get Physical, and in 2019, he memorably
reprised his role as Badger in El Camino:
A Breaking Bad Movie.
In March 2014, Lucas Black made his first
appearance as Special Agent Christopher LaSalle
on NCIS.
Then in September of that year, he began his
long-running stint on the spin-off series
NCIS: New Orleans and quickly became a fan
favorite.
But in Season 6, LaSalle was unceremoniously
shot while trying to avenge the death of his
brother.
"Christopher…?
God, no!"
Some fans are worried that NCIS: New Orleans
won't feel like the same show without Black:
He was an absolutely essential part of the
series.
Some viewers suspected he left because of
bad blood behind the scenes, but the truth
is actually far less dramatic than that.
It sounds like Black just wants to spend more
time with his family.
"There's a lot of priorities in my life that
get sacrificed for me to be here.
But it's time for me to focus on those priorities."
As for what acting gigs are in his future,
we'll just have to wait and see.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.